[Music]
all right so
there are a lot of words in
the english language english language
that we're not supposed to say
constipated bart say all of them go
constipated
giraffe uh-huh celebrity arugula
flabbergast is one of them kirkland
i feel probably saying just arugula by
itself but continue whatever tomfoolery
tom fuller can't say that and osmosis
you're not about
you say reverse osmosis forget about it
and then spermaneita
yes in that accident that one that one's
up for debate
spell money is up for debate so
oh [ __ ] okay well it seems uh
we all know what words we're not
supposed to say in public
it seems like every year there's a it's
a growing list
of words that you're not supposed to say
and you know obviously you know it can
be inflammatory
it can be hurtful some some of these
words put some ice on it
yeah they need to do some cold
challenges
oh yeah you chick put some ice
cool them down yeah that's a real chill
pill right there give them a cold shower
but yeah so some words now that are
being added to this list
uh are the words insane
psycho whoa lame
moronic and crazy you can't say lame or
real
lame they don't like gnarls barkley dude
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] you can't say
like make me
crazy have you actually heard the lyrics
of that song i heard like a slowed down
version of that song and it's actually
quite beautiful
i remember when i remember i remember
when i lost
is there any like context to it so the
context of this it's under
the term ableism have y'all heard of
that oh cause i know lame refers to
somebody who uh can't walk
well they should call them pirates i
don't even know that
that's much better that's a better
alternative pirate you know they can't
walk yeah or like they they don't have
used their likes i remember
like in fourth grade they're like all
right here read this story it was called
the lame prince and everybody laughed
and
the teacher was like no lame stands for
somebody who like can't walk
oh i see so it's a prince that can't
walk yeah i don't i don't remember the
story that makes me feel bad for how i
call
everybody lame that is wild that's safe
that's wild because you can't say that's
crazy can you say
wild still can we fall under another cat
i don't know
i i don't know so ableism as defined by
a disability activist uh is a system of
oppression that favors able-bodiedness
at any cost
frequently at the expense of people with
disabilities as a representative of the
crazy community though
i stand for my usage of the word crazy
when referring to something that is
outrageous out of this world out of the
box
and something that's really really
extraordinary and i
use it as a positive thing so it's crazy
that's a good i think that's a good
defense for that so we'll keep it
tell me the the terms again crazy crazy
psycho couple of them yeah insane psycho
lame moronic and
crazy okay cool so yeah they won't take
[ __ ] from us
yeah that's our words it's ours [ __ ]
what about jive turkeys
sex workers aren't going to get obsessed
oh i guess their word
why don't do it so i don't work who
claims [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh i see sex workers i like
saying [ __ ]
you're being a real [ __ ] right now
so if you have to change the title
of crazy rich asians it'd be like cuckoo
rich asians
oh true that movie is not it's it's it's
spreading ableism
anymore yeah either you gotta say um
no maybe it's just gotta be literal
ridiculous
no you can't say ridiculous wait yeah
you can can
this is ridiculous i think you could say
every day you can yeah i don't know for
now
yeah i do i think you can yeah it's a
ridiculous clown possible you're not
gonna take them serious
this is scary but this is this is based
off
uh wait what i can't say you can't say
bonkers bonkers and crazy refer to
people that are mentally ill can you say
wacko
uh probably not i don't think so i don't
know
what about like um like my my week was
so hectic that i am just
crippled by this amount of work that's
another word that's in here
you can't say crippled wait is this is
this one guy's thoughts
this is actually a couple different
professors how many of them
i didn't count the numbers if professor
x is not a part of this
i don't believe it if there's any
professor that could say it would be
professor
he should be the leader of disabilities
that is insane the simple fact that it's
not a real person
wait what oh you mean you're kidding me
are you you're gonna pull this on us
right now are you serious
i literally grew up watching him like
how can you say that to a gunshot victim
you were watching the documentaries
of professor x yeah no let's bring him
out guys professor x come on out
he just rolls out he's like no
i'm taking a [ __ ] right now but yeah
back to crippled
yeah they're saying you shouldn't use
the word crippled because people that
can't walk
might take offense to that and
alternatives to that
would be frozen by stopped by completely
stuck
what about people that are stuck people
have been stuck in quicksand
yeah what about all the stepsisters that
are stuck
under the bed yeah what are you doing
step bro
yeah oh all the step sisters that are
stuck in a laundry machine like what are
you what are we doing can we talk about
that
they're not going to be cool with this
can we talk about that why is that a
porn genre of like people getting stuck
in
not until you said washing machine did i
get it it was a porn genre
and then like i think i've been out of
the porn game for a while i didn't know
that was even john ross
i didn't know i didn't know what that
was until people would put it like memes
about it and i was like
oh is this a thing so i guess they get
stuck in the and i mean step mom
step sisters and just people get
stuck we said under a bunk bed i thought
of step brothers and i was like but he
said sisters
i'm confused they just get stuck and
then i don't think they would like
us using that word you know yeah i feel
kind of stuck well what about them what
other alternatives can we use
uh so instead of saying the word crazy
or bonkers
you can say wild confusing i don't like
the wild
unpredictable impulsive reckless
fearless
i don't like that impulsive one either
ridiculous impulsive
yeah it's true i don't know uh lives on
the edge
thrill seeker risk taker and out of
control i take offense the thrill seeker
yeah because that's what you are
that is what i am yeah and she's not
abnormal she's just a thrill
seeker skeeter i mean we're all we're
all
cracking jokes and stuff but if it
really hurts people like if it's really
like offensive then
yeah let's just stop saying it's just
the alternative doesn't make sense right
so one of them is um
if you can't say crazy but you can say
impulsive
there are impulsive people in the world
yeah so you're still
doing the same thing you're you're
referencing a trait
a personality trait or something that
can be harmful or hurtful towards
someone that's true yeah yeah that's
true because then
yeah exactly everyone can take anything
personal identity
to these terms and then find offense
basketball
if the shoe fits you know yeah it's like
you do this with comedy right we're
talking about this other day
and we're just talking about how like if
somebody has a joke about
a family member dying of cancer or
something when a comedian says it on
stage
they're not talking about you in
particular yeah you know i mean if you
had a family member that died of cancer
you know i mean it's like i don't know
it's a slippery
huge sitting inside yeah you
[ __ ] right there i'm talking to
you and your grandparents
cause you know like now we don't say the
f word and then we don't say
the r word because now we know it's
being like
widely loved
what common knowledge that it is a very
very offensive
very hurtful to people in those groups
so isn't it funny how it shifted where
like
people would go to jail for saying [ __ ]
or whatever on stage
and now everyone just says [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] all day yeah but then all
the words that they did say
openly back then like racial slurs or
whatever even on tv or whatever
uh they didn't go to jail for but now
it's a hate crime
so it's like sure you get words and
meanings i think they change over time
what is offensive what's hurtful it just
keeps changing
so who knows you know 20 years from now
what it's gonna be that's cool it's
gonna hurt yeah that's right for me i
think like
i would prefer all words are okay and
what you're really listening to is the
person's intent
and story and context and all that
because like if you've if you've been in
any sports locker room or just sports
talk
you're saying probably the most craziest
[ __ ] to each other like if me and nick
are training us to probably say crazy
[ __ ] to each other and if you
transcribed it on paper it's gonna look
crazy as [ __ ]
but we know that we have a certain
camaraderie and fraternity
and like a a certain relationship you
know so it's like to me it's all about
i think intent is more imper it's more
important
than isolating one word like crazy it's
like
what is he really trying to say how
about in the moments of when the intent
is to be hurtful then it's under
we already have laws of for that for the
stage
no i mean there's laws against um
harassment
you know threats yeah and things like if
you use
anything and it could be you know
harmful words
uh and it's assault verb like not verb
uh what do you call it
uh like intimidation things like that
there's already definitions for these
types of
forms of aggression that you can go to
jail for or get in trouble for
yeah for me it's like if their intent is
bad you punish the intent
still don't punish the words because
then that's like infringing on freedom
of speech kind of well just like we need
we need a slippery slope so like as we
get more intelligent
um we need to have more ways of
expressing ourselves
and so if we start taking away the
different colors of your like
paint bucket or whatever and you can
only paint with
just blue or or yellow you're going to
be limited in the way that you can
express things
like censoring emojis yeah because like
once you like put certain emojis
together then it's a fencer or whatever
yeah so for me i'm like have as many
colors as many crayons as possible
so people can express themselves fully
but then you have to understand where
the antenna is coming from and that's
personally what i would like more like
this article they're saying
the term blind spot can be
can perpetuate false ideas about what
living and working with a disability is
like
but when i'm driving a car and i'm
saying hey can you check my blind spot
am i what else are you supposed to say
am i talking about like a blind person
no it's in the context of me driving my
car and if i don't check my blind spot
i'm gonna hit another [ __ ] you can't
see because people that are blind can't
see so it's like it really
is so to me it's more important it's
like if i'm his passenger i'm like
is nick trying to make fun of someone
right now or he's
telling me to ensure the scene you're
the blind man
that he's asking to check the blind spot
then there's issues
if i'm the blind person i'm it's still
up to me
to hear the intent of working
[Laughter]
what happened after a blind person to
take the blind
block
if i did that in the back seat and
you're like can you check the blind spot
and you're like i can't see you stupid
[ __ ] yeah if i do that as a joke i'm
the [ __ ] yeah yeah
dude i know the joke i'm yeah bart check
my blind spot
yeah cancel me dude right [ __ ] dick
wife
yeah i i think that this is i understand
you know like the emotions that can go
behind you know especially if you're
if you're um to say a disabled person i
can understand why
uh you know certain emotions negative
emotions would come from the word crazy
or crippled
um but then yeah like slippery slope is
it like the fact that it's a slippery
slope like for example one
one of the directors at this university
who has a disability is in a wheelchair
he takes offense to the fact that people
when they go out for lunch they're like
let's walk over to quiznos let's walk
over to burger king
he's like i don't like the phrase let's
all walk over i think what we can do
is as a society try to
nudge people to act a certain way right
but when it comes to
legality like making it a lull and
that you can't can't regulate this and
then you punish them you get jail time
or whatever it is
i or you get a fine for saying things i
think
legally it's [ __ ] up but socially we
can get together
and be like you know what i don't think
we should communicate this way
and use these words but then to me
they're two separate things yeah like
you can only ask
someone to to not use that word but then
now when you bring force and
uh control and government into the
picture then we remove actual freedom of
speech
yeah so i think i think there's one way
to deal with it where it's like
hey man you don't want to say uh stuff
like
hey can you you're like a chick in the
armor or some [ __ ] you know
the chinese guy be like like what the
[ __ ] dude like are you talking about
chinese people
right and you could have a conversation
and be like oh maybe i shouldn't use
that because it could be confused as
like i'm talking about
chinks or whatever right and then or
like i don't know
you you evolve from using certain terms
yeah
as a society we can do that but then
making it a law that's kind of weird
but it's also like these are professors
saying this right i have a really hard
time believing that if
a friend who happens to be in a
wheelchair heard me say the phrase hey
guys let's walk over here
do you think they would really be like
yo dude what the [ __ ] are you saying
like a true homie yeah like do you think
he would take that to a fence
i have a whole really hard time thinking
that i also agree that that
taking that offense that drastically is
a little excessive because it
if it really does hurt to that extent
then there's just a simple conversation
and being like
or you could even joke about it like
well i guess i won't see you there
because i can't walk over there or
whatever it is
but like there could be just like
multiple conversations with
each individual or whatever that is
using terminology and then
with the individuals getting personally
affected by it we should all
ask people if they're okay with it or
not and
and figure out the rules within the
family and the group yeah not like make
it this whole
no everyone has to be one way nothing is
universal right like
very few things are universal not even a
universal remote universal exactly and
they're all
they all don't work yeah so uh i don't
know this is uh
quite up for david debate i guess uh let
us know in the comments what you guys
think about ableism